hello YouTube welcome to the Reuben
report I'm the guy who invented
healthcare.gov dave rubin I've got Beth
Troutman and kira soltanovich with me
and let's roll okay Obamacare have you
heard they're having some problems the
rollout has been a disaster websites not
working something like six people signed
up on the first day and now it turns out
maybe the president lied about how it's
all gonna work let's go to the videotape
you can keep your plan if you are
satisfied with it if you like the plane
you have you can keep it if you like
your plan and you like your doctor you
won't have to do a thing you keep your
plan if you like your health care plan
you'll be able to keep your health care
plan if you've got health insurance you
can keep it if you like your health care
plan you will keep your plane if you've
got health insurance you like your
doctor you like your plan you can keep
your doctor you can keep your plan if
you have insurance that you like then
you will be able to keep that insurance
if you like your doctor or healthcare
plan you can keep it if you like your
health care plan you can heat keep your
health care plan if you like your health
care plan you can keep it or something
like that yeah okay there's many more
examples of that we've all seen it we've
been talking about this on the show for
a while now I believe that Obamacare is
something that is important to the
country people should have a right to
universal health care all that good
stuff but the rollout is a disaster and
Obama on Monday explained a little bit
about what he really meant when he was
saying all that other stuff now if you
have or had one of these plans before
the Affordable Care Act came into law
and you really like that plan what we
said was you could keep it if it hasn't
changed since the laws passed so we
wrote into the Affordable Care Act
you're grandfathered in on that plan but
if the insurance company changes it then
what we're saying is they've got to
change it to a higher standard they've
got to make it better they've got to
improve the quality of the plan that
they're so okay so that seems like a
pretty big if there was no if before
that right so my first
question to you guys is this his sort of
George Bush no new taxes Bill Clinton I
did not have sexual relations with that
woman moment this is really a semantic
argument I mean if he came out of just
said hey you know we we misspoke the
issue really is that these health care
plans are now meeting a new standard so
if if these people are losing their
health care plans they're going to have
to pay more it's because they're going
to end up with better coverage so maybe
they paid 50 bucks before but if they
ended up having a detrimental disease
god forbid cancer they weren't going to
have the coverage that they needed or
deserved is especially now under
Obamacare right so his argument is that
the lowest standard is going to be
raised now at so that if you lost your
health care plan you're actually going
to get a better one but if he lied his
way into this why should we believe that
what did he really lie this is that not
a lie so that's what everyone's saying
did he willfully lie is this is
deception is this did they not really
tell him the truth so he didn't know
what he was gonna say look when you're
campaigning you have to find something
snappy and snazzy to say and I guarantee
you will I am or some hip hop artist is
gonna use that is gonna sample that now
it's going to be dropped into the next
you know whatever the summer tune is
gonna be you know if you keep it you can
have it like that you can do it i mean
they're gonna take obama's campaign
basically slogan and use it now because
it's catchy right it's catchy you can't
say if you like your health you know a
care plan you can keep it although
parentheses and inks exclamation and
here's what we have and hold on there's
more to it Astra's ok i just too long to
say all that i totally agree with you i
think that's what happened here I think
he knew that a certain amount of people
were gonna be kicked off their plan and
the hope was they were all gonna get
better insurance as you're saying right
but does isn't there some issue with the
the trust that we all want to trust this
guy there's something different about
Obama and I think people really want to
trust him and believe in him so when he
lies just for the campaign purposes I
think this somehow seems a little worse
we can't even like she says we can't
even really call it a lie that it's
really more of it was easier just to say
this and not do all the explanations on
the
background but if he came out and said
hey you know what we misspoke we're
sorry you're going to get better health
care and change is hard but once you get
into it and once you see that you're
going to have better coverage then
people are going to forgive him we're
very forgiving people and we have very
very short-term memories now so if he
just came out talked about it honestly
said hey look once we started once we
pass this bill and so many people so
many changes were made to it yeah all of
this all of this has changed the way
this all works but you're gonna have
better coverage in the long run people
are going to thank him I think for that
later on but accepting the change is the
hardest part because it's hard it's hard
to change its regard to change your plan
if you liked it because it was cheap
that if it didn't give you coverage
what's the point of even paying and in
expand for an inexpensive plan right so
then the real question here is can you
believe after he makes the initial miss
truth or what do we want to call it give
me a word the rap lyric the rapper that
you're alluding to right can we then by
his next statement which is everybody's
is going to get better because doesn't
that seem a little how often does that
happen in government or in anything
we're gonna do something and everybody
is we get a better situation how to act
look I love my insurance plan that I
have right I have a 7000 all deductible
and you know I don't get any kind of you
know prescription stuff because I don't
take drugs but you know it's awesome
like I don't have any extra eye care
dental which is perfect because those
only things I really care about so other
than that I really love my plan but if
you don't like your plan and you may be
you know call 911 now it's going to be
covered and it's hard to explain all
that to most of America you know who I'm
talking to and they don't get that if
your plan doesn't have let's say
maternity you know leave or things like
that or like emergency things that come
up you're going to now have it is just
going to be basic for everyone yeah you
will have the basic things I think he
should have said if you like it you're
gonna like it more right that's what he
should said why is why are they not
calling me Franklin
stuff I don't know she didn't write it
well you only have consulted him and
saved him a lot of heartache right and
if you would've said that it wouldn't a
bit as catchy cuz if you like it you can
keep it period is just like perfect
right a deity makes you say if you like
it you can put a ring on it should have
done a little dance with it uh and i
think that would have worked yeah so
then my final question on this is do you
guys think that in general in a
philosophic sense do you think the ends
justify the means if he had to do this
sort of trickery or lie or whatever we
want to call it to get this thing passed
and at the end it's going to be good and
more people will have coverage and
better coverage do the ends justify the
means to the lie and the miss truth
justify everyone getting something
better in the end if we're going on the
assumption it's going to be look altima
tlie i think it is going to be better
and if we talk about the fact that
people are going to have mammograms now
that people can now get genetic
screening for things like cancer and it
has to be covered if people aren't going
to be dropped because they get sick or
because they have a pre-existing
condition that is a big big change and
that's a really awesome thing but people
won't really understand it until they
have to really go until they have that
experience and a lot of little too can
you try to answer not even kill I know
what you're saying until you're almost
dying from lung cancer then you'll be
like oh I get it now I like it and I
like it more right so you think the ends
do justify the means that thinks so he
omitted and I know you were saying
something about semantics and I don't
know what juice had to do with it but
omitted information that just would have
been too long to get into right right a
sticker a bumper sticker right that's
all you have time for slogans rest of it
people would again short attention spans
people would have tuned out to the rest
of it but would say a new Obamacare you
get better attention spans because now
you have a doctor that can take care of
your attention yeah very good I don't
know what's the a.d.d medication I keep
forgetting
clearly a Madeleine ever well as you can
see all right well then I I kind of
think that the ends don't necessarily
justify the means if you screwed up the
process even if you get something good
out of it but that's what makes a world
go around all right so the US is having
a bit of a mini crisis with Saudi Arabia
right now Saudi Arabia is one of our
biggest allies in the Gulf but they've
been upset about what we've been doing
with Iran and what's happening in Syria
and just last week the United States
said we support the universal rights of
the Saudi Arabian people and what we
were alluding to there was basically
women's rights because women cannot
drive in Saudi Arabia this is 2013 a
couple years ago a law was passed that
eventually they'll be allowed to drive
and eventually they'll be allowed to
vote it's very confusing but then John
Kerry was speaking last week and they're
trying to fix up this whole diplomatic
kerfuffle and here's what he said it's
no secret that in the United States of
America we embrace equality for
everybody regardless of gender race or
any other qualification but it's up to
Saudi Arabia to make its own decision
about its own social structure and
choices and timing okay I basically am
on board that with the United States
should not be dictating to the world how
they're allowed to run their internal
affairs that seems to be why everybody
hates us but it does seem kind of weird
to me that in 2013 with a country that's
considered an ally of ours we're not
allowed to say to them maybe women
should just be equal like like women
having equality doesn't even seem like a
real issue to me to sure we have no
influence whatsoever in the country's
domestic of it I hope that we have
influence and I think we should have
influenced Minh if you look at the
global community and just look at videos
that are going viral of women who were
risking themselves and their they're
getting behind the wheel and people are
loving it even men dressing up as
winners are getting behind the wheel and
driving and people are wanting to watch
it but just recently somebody was drive
a woman was driving out of Kuwait into
Saudi Arabia with her diabetic father
that she was trying to get to the
hospital she was arrested she was
detained as she was crossing the border
even though she had a real purpose to be
behind the wheel of that car you hope
that things like that and that if the
global community and the United States
if we get in on that dialogue you would
hope that we would have an impact and I
think that we should not just at the
fence but you know with a lot of this
this has an economic impact and that's
one of the things they're they're
they're hedging their bets I guess
they're watching out because we have an
economic interest in Saudi Arabia and I
would imagine that that is why this is
so so you think it might have sorry be
with oil actually I think you were
trying to say later what I think should
we have any influence she was arrested
that woman um no no that won't not you
bet that was arrested I was the one
driving she did not wave when someone
let her into a lane so that's why so
you're driving technicality well you
should be arrested if you don't wave and
I let you in God there better be a
police car signal is given some sort of
thank you yeah I think that it is
obviously politically driven and there
is a part of me that as a chick yeah
contrary crazy I know right contrary to
what people are saying i am a trick um
but that yeah i'd like to see women not
have to wear the burqa I know I know ah
but they can't drive in that Burke have
you seen some of them some of them cover
like they have a special veil that
covers their eyes like they shouldn't be
driving if their feet are gonna get all
caught up in the brake and the gas then
you know what a break there's a lot
going on yeah but I I get upset more
about other things than just the driving
the driving just seems like yes that you
should be able to get in your car or
whatever a vehicle anything and go if
you want freedom it's it's part of the
freedom but there are so many other
issues right that are more pressing that
are definitely where I don't think
nothing son of our business but we're
never gonna get anywhere you mean our
own domestic issues here no then in
Saudi Arabia yeah so we're doing the
house you can't without a man it who's a
relative to another dude or else they're
like hey hussy get in the red light
district you right I asked him
what time it was well they just let them
vote they think that you a year or
something yeah but they still care drive
to the polls okay right yeah so it's
just such a serious and they can't go
without a chaperone Andy things are
being able to vote who they want to vote
for it were they gonna vote for who
daddy and husband and brothers say you
should vote for right so
there's so much more other than like I
want a Ford Focus like there's more on
earth who you guys are sponsored by yeah
that's right you can say you know i
don't i don't think that that I feel
like is the least of my issues with
women in Saudi Arabia right do you guys
think we should have just sort of basic
standards if you're gonna be an ally the
United States you have to just have a
basic standard women should be treated
equally I mean simple things you
shouldn't be killing gay p but is that
my favorite a lie no no of course so we
can't conflate those who they know it'd
be ideal if we could do I'm sure a big
deal animated say that if we would all
say hey you guys stop supporting Justin
Bieber's career you know the idea
because a lot of things but I don't
think that we get even close to being
able to tell them what to do because
there are hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of religious years that are way
stronger than you know John Kerry and
the United States of America but the
world has gotten smaller though now
because of the internet so it becomes an
issue that everybody gets involved in
rather than just the people of Saudi
Arabia so that can put pressure on their
culture which I think it already has you
see changes but it's not happening
quickly enough I think for a lot of
people does this social also show sort
of just our general hypocrisy about
everything I mean Iran which we're
dealing with some other stuff with
related to the nukes that women are
allowed to drive their women are allowed
to drive in Syria so we have countries
that we keep pushing as the enemy that
treat their women better than one of our
biggest allies in the region that's why
I'm saying it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter we are not going to be able to
get along with another country because
they let their chicks paint their
toenails just I'm saying it's not gonna
it's not going to help anything in the
longer they have to as a society decide
you know that that is really
inappropriate to not allow a woman to
talk to another man like what is it what
is it within you guys as a society that
makes you fear a chick with opinions but
basically yeah show me on the doll where
you were touched either I mean because
obviously you have a much larger problem
than just you know stick shift let's
move off this planet into the bigger
galaxy a new study shows that one in
five sun-like stars in this galaxy are
surrounded by planets that could meet
some of the basic prerequisites for life
like we have here the study was
published in the Journal of proceedings
of the national academy of science and
is based on a three-year examination of
data from NASA's Kepler space telescope
but let's look at some other numbers the
findings were that scientists calculated
that twenty-two percent of stars are
just like our Sun and have planets
similar to earth with a margin of error
of plus or minus eight percent so that
that's kind of that's kind of big but
that's still big number we're talking
about there are about 200 billion stars
in our galaxy with about 40 to 50
billion of them like our Sun meaning
there would be at least eight point
eight planets like ours that are
probably inhabitable and have some sort
of life and if they've got some water
and some air maybe they have intelligent
life even though we don't have any here
do you think are there space creatures
out there I love the idea of it and i
know some astro physicist are probably
gonna get me on this one but i love the
idea that maybe some of these planets
are like parallel universes where a lot
of us exist on all of these different
planets just in different time periods
with different decisions that mean well
you're real you're Joba question but
it's a fun thing to think about and
there are so many people who already
believe that they have seen aliens or
seen UFOs are seen lie from from other
planets and this is just kind of giving
them some hey yeah it's possible yeah do
we have any reason not to think there's
life anywhere else I know people don't
want it religion doesn't want you to
believe that but it's see when you look
at something like this you know our star
our Sun is just like a very simple star
it's nothing great and they're showing
you that there's tons of others out
there can you imagine the Twitter
followers you would have if we can you
imagine how many more people watching
the Reuben report I mean granted they
they speak in cliques but they'll be
watching you for other galaxies great
yeah just in terms of numbers you know I
think that Beth is right I do think that
maybe that this whole you know the our
whole Milky Way could just be like a
mirror image of another galaxy I mean
how do I know we're not just looking
into some crazy fun house mirror so
we're looking into this Kepler by the
way
Kepler guy bag what a what a sack on
this guy naming all the planets that he
found Kepler 69 can't believe me it's
like come on do you can you name
something else yeah they're not gonna be
happy about Kepler when they find out
that they are planet whatever they named
it and we're at 42 f yeah yeah because
of Twitter because yeah they will yeah
they'll be pissed but I think what if
it's just a big fun house mirror and
we're just looking at ourselves did I
just blow your mom ain't no the fun
house Mary thing yeah I get that I think
that is kind of possible but I think
might be a little more possible would be
that there's all these planets that are
at different stages of evolution right
because there's just different some of
them are gonna be less advanced than us
because life start because maybe the
planets a little closer to the Sun so
for some reason they advanced a little
slower especially your ass yeah so it's
earlier or later how about that I lead
an earlier us I totally have to send a
message it's a seventh-grade me yeah I
don't know if you're listening Kepler 47
but that is not his brother all right
I'm sorry she'll know what I mean she'll
know yeah yeah yeah it was it was a
school dance well story should we be
putting more research into this kind of
stuff do you think I think so I mean it
this is a fantastic it's a fantastic
field and now we have the technology on
this planet to actually send up
telescopes that we can see far off in
into other galaxies why not put more
research into it because you never know
what we can find although we don't want
it to turn into you know a place where
we're going to another planet to mine
for resources the avatar yeah yeah
behtari thing you don't want that to
happen or what if we are really in like
horton hears a who right like what if we
are it like we think that we're so smart
but really there's a whole nother planet
that's watching us and like taking care
of us or a whole nother galaxy rather
yeah they're taking care of us that's
like the episode of The Simpsons with
Lisa's little tooth that's great
civilization yes one of my one of my
favorites um can we trust our government
to do this properly if we would ever
make contact or contact was made with us
can we trust the people that are in
charge not to screw it up or is there
any I mean it seems to me we're gonna
meet aliens one day and either they're
gonna kill us or we're gonna kill them I
don't see any way really
where we don't and some whoever's more
advanced doesn't end up destroying
colonizing the avatar theory I think we
send government to talk to him we sing
comedians same peeps don't really uh
yeah interesting you have the first
conversations with you know actual
people that don't talk in sound bites
you have actual conversations loosen
them up a little bit and then maybe the
relationships can start with the bigger
that's what then begun comedian on the
panel yeah we should push in the comics
out there as the International do and
they're like I she said and then we give
them the blankets with syphilis yeah
here you go yeah exactly uh I think we
wrap that one up unless you have any
other I figured it out thought I mean I
would love it I don't think in our
lifetime though unfortunately I mean
unless our lifetime is actually also
happening in a perpendicular galaxy
right and happen with that the electric
currents that you create through thought
according to certain yesterday we all
just drop shrooms hell parallel
universes are created I don't know if
it'll be our generation but I think our
kids kids kids generations will probably
have some sort of contact all right well
as long as we're talking about all this
stuff that's a perfect transition to
weed people as we did it happen actually
just yesterday in the election Colorado
they're gonna start taxing weed now and
you know it's already recreationally
legal there and it's I think also got
voted in it in Portland Oregon yesterday
so good stuffs happening in the weed
Department and an according to a new
report that was obtained by The
Huffington Post legal marijuana is among
the fastest-growing markets in the
United States and it's growing at a rate
posed to outpace the expansion of the
global market in smartphones and can I
just say that backwards I think I said
that slightly backwards anyway
researchers surveyed hundreds of medical
cannabis retailers processors dispensary
owners and industry leaders over six
months to a year researchers estimated
that more than 1.4 three billion worth
of legal marijuana will be sold in 2013
that figure is expected to grow by 64%
to 2.3 4 billion next year by comparison
recent figures show the smartphone
market expanded by forty six percent
from
twenty twelve to twenty thirteen i'm
going to go out on a limb here and say
you guys are pleased with this and that
there's no problem with the level of i
have stock in funyuns so i am very happy
very very happy about this i don't
personally partake in the legal or
illegal and you know drugs but i can
confirm that we were at a party and I
saw you just say no I did I'm not saying
anything about myself yeah you and
everyone had their clothes on just one
total yeah I did date say just say no
yeah um but it was saying no because
this Saudi chick wanted to drive that's
what I was talking about I don't know if
you yeah yeah but all that cause I'm in
a crack yeah um I uh I think that if we
can tax this are we are we taxing this
yeah yeah so we California needs to tax
this desperately we need to take this
marijuana money and put it into our
schools so that our kids can know
marijuana gave me an education but I
mean I think that we need to definitely
grab on to some of that's a lot of money
and I think it should be legal and I
think it should I don't think these
should dispensary should be uh you know
shut down because federal people all of
a sudden come in and go hey wait a
second we know it's legal in your state
but we're kind of we don't like the fact
that you guys are making money and we
don't making to do with it so we're
gonna shut it down yeah just to spite
you so just to clarify that so that's
actually what's happening now so even in
California where every we could walk out
of here and go within a mile we could
probably find five pot dispensaries it's
legal here in California but the feds do
come in sometimes yeah and sees
everything take all the money shut the
place down and all that is this just one
of these things sort of like gay rights
where as equality comes around people
realize oh it didn't destroy straight
marriage it didn't destroy the army
everything's okay and as we'd get to
legalize people realize I didn't do that
much bad stuff well that's a key issue I
mean as this younger population ages and
they start voting I mean marijuana just
isn't to these young people what it is
to older folks now and if you really
look at research a most research doesn't
point to any kind of negative effect
that marijuana has on at the human body
they're just kind of speculating that
there's a problem and
really really frankly serious about
marijuana there are some huge health
benefits and people especially people
who are battling cancer I have a mother
who has ovarian cancer and marijuana has
been shown to actually shrink the size
of tumors stop the blood flow to tumors
and that's a huge issue and if we can
get in on that make money off of that
tax that and have no negative side
effects that you know some of the
medications that we have for treating
cancer along with it that is HUGE and if
just to talk about the money itself i
think if you talked to any dealer they
could have told you how much money was
actually in marijuana get it right ask
them and then all of that going back
into our system rather than you know
somewhere here or there and everybody
can you can stop the fighting on the
border with your drug cartels and all
that I think what Beth is saying is you
know with the marijuana helping health
wise if you like your weed you can keep
your weight right I think that's really
what that's like illegal yeah if you
like your weed you can keep you know
whatever you're calling your cush cush
cush cush she's a very cushion that can
you imagine if the legalization of
marijuana threatened gay marriage oh and
we came full circle we fought so hard
you know what were equality cake
marriage I beard and then it just ah if
legalizing weed was gonna cost gay
marriage I'd be okay for you all right
so is this as part of this though the
reason that it's taking so long with
weed sort of just the cliche thing about
weed is when you smoke it you're a
little lazier so it's like the Olympians
no they're playing video games and you
know playing hacky sack so you know it's
hard to like get a real grassroots lobby
no pun intended grass okay think about
the people who are you know in their 30s
and 40s right now they're part of the
just say no generation they're part of
the Nancy Reagan you know enforcing the
different kind of lingo they have that
kind of in their heads that it's a bad
thing it's going to be a gateway drug to
other drugs and yeah that's where the
thought process is but this younger
generation is coming in with this idea
that there are all kinds of health
benefits what do you make is a gateway
drug thing I find that to be the
stupidest possible thing because it
implies somehow that if you took weed
away that nobody would get in runs but
you would just start at a harder drug
right I mean isn't it just and that
didn't you
would be cocaine would be the Gateway
things right exactly heroin would be the
gateway drug that would well I mean I
ate glue as a child and everyone said
that's the Gateway but you just look I
know so what go so the Gateway theory is
there was something there was something
there guys yeah there was something
there but here we go because I ate glue
I forgot what I was talking about yeah
at the end of the day to make this
really happen do we need big farmer to
get behind it like ya know you don't
know we're gonna make bars for sure but
no do we need because the drug the
prescription drug companies that give us
all these drugs that make us have
suicidal thoughts and diarrhea hmm you
know wrestled all that's do you want to
talk about your morning no every
commercial half the commercials about
that stuff right right but that we that
they're gonna try to stop weed as much
as possible because they can't have some
sort of naturally growing that's gonna
do all those good things I thought
you're saying get them involved like get
them behind it no no that but I'll give
it to make it to really make it legal
because of all the power they have yeah
they're gonna somehow steal the thunder
behind this thing the great thing would
be is if the voters if the population
made it so that you don't elect people
who are really really against it and
then Big Pharma doesn't have to get
involved because they're not gonna have
the power like turn this is a very
idealistic view but turn the power back
to the people let the voters make the
decision and then everybody else is
gonna have to have to catch up and these
people who are already doing it are
gonna be on the forefront of it and
they're gonna end up making a lot of the
money and maybe some of the power will
go away from big farm yeah the health
care that's right yeah and that's what's
happening right now but that's my point
that that's big pharma sphere so I feel
like automatically just cuz of the
amount of money they have they're gonna
somehow get in on this and screw it up
listen you want to get your weed from
some guy named dirt man Sam who lives in
Venice Beach yes who you have to
literally like go underneath in a
basement in a crawl space to get to his
apartment and that's where you want to
get your weed you don't want to walk
into a save on or a CVS and get your
wheat that takes out the old uh you know
fun out of it this coming from someone
who doesn't smoke weed I don't know what
worked of you or know people get their
weed is never how everyone got it here
all the people working here no no
they're all glaucoma they have glaucoma
they have a cards you know words i
really i really hope that it does find
some sort of middle ground it doesn't
get too big farm i don't want it to get
to that place but i don't want it just
to be kind of gross and back alley and
you know gun fights right you know i
mean with cartels that it just you know
stays but like you said in the people's
hands like with that one hot nurse who
wears a white lab coat on Venice Beach
telling you to come in if you have a
headache right she's qualified no no one
we're dealing I'm talking about we're
getting our weed buying advice from the
girl who doesn't smoke tell we haven't
seen that chicken a white lab coat on
Venice Beach selling hot yes yes yes all
right oh we're gonna take a little field
trip we got us go down right now all of
us all right let's move on okay so this
is a really this is a big story I'm
gonna give you a lot of information here
but I think we can do this even though
this is YouTube and attention spans are
short so Iceland literally went bankrupt
Iceland is a country of 320,000 people
so a very small country and they the
International Monetary Fund and the
European Union wanted to take control of
Iceland's debt and the people of Iceland
basically were like wait a minute we
didn't do this this was all the bankers
that were doing this is very small
amount of people that were doing this
and they decided that they were going to
fire all the bankers and put them in
jail and that they were going to take
control of their debt so there were
riots there were protests and eventually
the government resigned okay are you
with me so far like we got all out here
so then the government resigns they vote
in a new government and the new
government says we are going to have you
all pay a hundred euros a month for 15
years at five percent interests and
that's going to pay off the deck but the
people still weren't happy about that
because they didn't incur the debt this
was again this was bankers and all this
financial trickery they didn't want to
do that so why am i bringing this all up
because i think this is a great great
story eventually they kicked out the
government and they figured out a way to
make the debt basically go away and not
have the world come in and control the
icelandic economy so the head of state
refused to ratify the law that would
have made iceland citizens responsible
for its bankers debts and accepted calls
for a referendum Interpol put out an
Internet
arrest warrant for the ex-president of
calc thing that's the biggest bank there
and the other bankers implicated in the
crash fled the country they decided to
draft a new constitution that would free
the country from the exaggerated power
of international financial and virtual
money we got a little bit more here and
then they decided to write a new
constitution the people of Iceland
elected 25 citizens from among 522
adults not belonging to any political
party but recommended by at least 30
citizens the document was written on the
internet and constituents meetings are
streamed online and citizens can send
their comments and suggestions
witnessing the document as you take
shape okay giving you a lot of stuff
there but I the reason I thought this
was important is because we have such a
problem with money and politics here and
these people they actually said no to
the banks they said no to the bailouts
they fired and put people in jail who
did everything wrong it is completely
the reverse of everything we've done in
this country we bailed these people out
nobody got fired and these and they got
rid of the debt debt that they did not
incur the regular people like the three
of us did not they are not incurred and
saddled with the debt I think this is a
great story and it's completely
underreported and now I've talked a lot
so please I am so thrilled that you're
actually covering this story because
this is an actual story of returning
power to people what people in this
country actually talk about and the
thing that we don't do the other thing
that's really amazing this is like the
modern version of the Continental
Congress they're coming in there they're
drafting new legislation a new
constitution but then beyond that
they're getting input from the web from
people who are watching it virtually
this is absolutely incredible it's like
it's like electing a delegate and then
being there as they represent you it's
an awesome thing to watch it happens
yeah and everything about this is the
reverse of how we do things here so not
only firing the bankers and putting
people in jail which we don't do but
having it be an open process remember
even when Obamacare was getting past
they said oh well everyone will be
welcome and we'll put it on c-span but
never happened it was all behind closed
doors is there any chance we can look at
something like this and go we
better hi I'm Erica I wish maybe in
maybe in sherman oaks california well
Josh I'm saying cuz we have okay too
many people and with the amount of
people that we have and the history that
we have as a country yeah um they have
300,000 view but more people watch the
superbowl then they have in their entire
country yeah more and more people watch
an average football game that is it
suitable yeah so of course they can kind
of come to some sort of agreement and
all the people and I hate to say this
but the backgrounds of the people are
pretty much the same you know that's
Norse yeah background right so they can
all kind of agree on what will my
grandfather and my grandfather they all
thought the same thing when this country
we have it's a melting pot of people who
just got here yesterday yeah you know
from Iceland you know people that just
immigrated it they're not coming from
something that's true but you know we
just don't have that the same
consistency and continuity unfortunately
in this country so is that one of the
major catch-22 of America because the
melting pot is amazing it's what has
made America what it is but then when it
comes to something like this because we
all got any we can't agree on because
our shared experience is so different
I'll tell you I don't I don't
necessarily think it's the melting pot
issue that would cause a problem here I
think it's more our election process
that would cause a problem there's so
much money and we're seeing election
laws you overturned and people companies
now have freedom of speech and can put
millions and millions and millions of
dollars into specific political
candidates who then Oh a favor the
reason this thing won't happen here is
because of the way we elect our
officials and how we allow big money to
get into the process that's going to be
the real issue because I think once you
get into this country and you see how
things work I don't even know that it's
a difference in background that changes
the way that you think about it I think
people start seeing what might be better
we just can't get officials in who will
actually do it because our election
process is so messed up yeah so that
actually is a great said when I say
melting pot I do mean racism I'm sorry
should be more clear nope i usually like
we have a history in this country where
there's still a lot of anger and a lot
of inequality
and they just don't have that so much
smaller it's a smaller scale it's a
smaller country they don't have slavery
there you know they don't have this
history of like you know black people
couldn't vote until just you don't need
a few decades ago so that's why I
thought but it's big couples what you're
saying it's coupled with the election
process because we're so polarized
political we have the Democrats and in
the right wing then these liberals and
then no one's really in the middle and
they say they are but they're not and so
it muddies up everything and we can't
it's like we freaking Glee can't get
along I know that's such a terrible
bumper sticker to take it back to bumper
stickers but why can't we all just get
along they obviously figured it out in
Iceland yeah well doesn't it's also
going to show how the media is also in
bed with big money and big policy under
this cuz nobody knows about this storm a
nice about it yeah but I someone tweeted
about it as a Twitter yeah well there
you go but you know a lot of people this
is not the type of thing that's being
shown on CNN let's do it that way so
that media is not giving us a chance to
realize even that things can change cuz
they would never show this we think Fox
is gonna show a thing about about the
big banks not winning in the end like we
just have this theory here that we're
just sort of never gonna win and the sad
thing is is that these big media
companies now aren't just we're not just
talking about media here in the United
States you know you got a company like
Fox they're huge in Australia they're
huge in Europe so it's it's we're
dictating the conversation that's
happening globally not just aren't they
probably like twenty percent owned by
Saudi King by the way nobody else nobody
talks about that yeah but why has not
talked about yeah yeah his wife can't
drive okay yeah she probably she might
be only on the compound to their shoes
right in a golden yeah so can we twist
this anyway that's we're gonna feel good
about this end of this segment that
things can change positive they can but
you know it's hard to put Iceland on the
spotlight when you know all we know
about Iceland is New York and a swan
dress you shouldn't saying like no one
in this country even knows what Iceland
is yeah and so that's the first
challenge is getting people to actually
look outside of their little you know
their little neighborhood their little
cul-de-sac the crazy thing is is that
Iceland kind of represented what was
going on globally and people who were
really in the know actually looked to
Iceland even when the economic crisis
was happening so if they can look to
to Iceland to see what was going wrong I
mean they were basically exactly like a
smaller version of Wall Street just
making really bad financial decisions
and their economy grew nine times
between 2003 and 2007 and people were
looking to that is like what's going to
happen here so maybe they'll do the same
thing politically they can look to that
country of what could potentially happen
versus what happened here and then maybe
if people start hearing about it then
you've got an uprising and thanks to you
people are going to hear about it and
thank you to you for explaining that a
little clearer than I didn't actually
make me for anything thank you all right
be here thank you for thanking me we'll
put a link to the article right down
below so you can check that out and by
the way if you don't think that all the
banks and the countries are in on it all
together Britain and Hollins we're gonna
punish Iceland for not doing this so
this is just one big mess that I think
maybe this is a little story that we
could get a little bit from okay
everybody knows I'm a huge Star Wars fan
and that's why I wanted to touch on this
story so you may have heard about this
that in England right now there are a
hundred eighty thousand people who
identify as Jedi Knights yeah that's
right in the census under religion they
put other and they write in Jedi Knight
180,000 people they believe in a faith
called Jedi ism and let's get a little
explanation about what it is well what
do the Jedi actually believe how you
practice Jedi ism well it's a very
practices there's meditation there's
physical fitness there's a focus on
diplomacy and general etiquette you know
being nice opening doors that general
stuff there's also focus on community
service pictures as far as religious
beliefs that varies from person to
person if you're looking for something
in relation to God or a deity a specific
definition of the force that does vary
from jeddak two Jedi alright frankly I
would have liked my Jedi representative
to be a little more well-spoken a little
more confident but ok that's fine he's
doing alright almost everything I
learned is from the Star Wars movie this
basically is my mantra no why not
do or do not there is no try yeah that's
right Yoda taught me everything I know
okay so what I think is interesting
about this is if the basic mantra of us
is be good too man you know be socially
conscious all the good stuff let's
remove the lightsabers for a second is
this not a religion I mean what
qualifies as a religion it's great it's
a life philosophy and if you live by
this life philosophy you're going to be
a happier person and there's power in
that you know the power of positive
thinking it's a popular notion now you
know why not whatever whatever floats
your boat and if they're getting out
there and they're being good to people
and they're not killing in the name of
Jedi ism they're not conquering other
nations in the name of Jedi's and
they're not denying people reproductive
rights in the name of Jedi ism why not
you know let people let people be good
to each other and identify with with
what they want if they're in fact being
good to each other the key here is
kindness alright I've got another Jedi
condoms out here yeah are you on board
absolutely look I wish I was still a
virgin and kaleen in my parents basement
but that's not reality I don't know that
that's one of the tenants necessarily in
battle it definitely helps they all live
in their parents basements yeah I I
think that sure why not I mean it's it's
very it's very in right now to do like
cosplay right I'm gonna saying that card
but yeah I thought it really that was
just dressing up like Bill Cosby but no
type of cosplay and I was so embarrassed
I wore a big cable knit sweater for
Halloween I'm like look I'm cosplay and
they were like that's wrong i had a
jello thing I was it was it was
embarrassing yeah uh but I I do think
that like what Beth said if sure if you
believe in something that's basically
just don't be a douche right I think
that should be you know that's that's
the religion for example I have a almost
three year old kid and people like how
are you raising him you know cuz I'm
Jewish my husband's Catholic I'm like
we're raising him don't be a douche
douche don't be a douche ism can I can I
do Kira ism yes gonna do a new car sir
you started it now boom done please
follow me at don't be a douche diabetes
I twitter handle is don't be a douche
yeah I have to do that I know as part of
this though that it won't gain certain
amount of traction cuz when you look at
those pictures and you know you've got
the
I in the robe and he's stopping the car
people I so it's just based in fantasy
but at the same time everything in
religion Moses parting the Red Sea that
sounds like a jedi force trick or that
really happened that's the one that
happen ever that really happened yeah or
everyone's coming back from the dead all
that stuff so do you need some of that
mythology actually does that actually
help the cause to have some stuff that
really isn't real that helps the
religious maybe because you have to have
faith in order to believe it you know so
it's the same it's the same kind of
notion but if you follow the basic
tenants then you're going to be a good
person and you're going to have success
in this life because it's what you put
out there comes back to you and that's
basically what this is what this is
saying you can't make fun of people for
that i'll let you finish this thing you
would make it your own religion let you
bring you home now you can't google
image Jesus walking on water but you can
google you can google up you can watch
it's real it really happened that's
funny have it on celluloid that's
actually really funny cuz you know
really just people always want to go
back to the Bible and quote this or that
or that this now all you have to do is
oh well go to youtube and remember when
you go to said don't later and yeah
that's it three hundred years from now
people will be looking back at the Star
Wars footage like see it really happened
they'll be using it they are brother and
sister how could it ruin it for
everybody Oh God alright well I hope
we've given you a little faith here i
want to thank beth troutman kira
soltanovich there is a subscribe button
down below oh and by the way you might
have noticed that the panels a little
wacky here we're working on it up I
don't know I don't know what happened
but newly dispensary it's the same
people the exact I care subscribe thank
you guys will do it again next week okay